Telling a woman she should do something is actually antifeminist we're told all
the time from so many people what we should be,
how we should ask the question and it goes against what I believe as a feminist
anyway.
Okay.
I know
three,
two.
Wow.
Like I know like step one through five but like to actually do it,
I don't think I can like be confident enough to just do it,
you know?
Yeah.
I didn't know there were five steps anyways,
so that's why I'm here.
Like I have changed my tire multiple times,
just shows that I'm not a great driver,
but I learned myself and I had to because I popped my tire left
three,
two,
there shouldn't be any difference in the fundamental life things that we all
should know.
And I think that if we were all raised the same,
there wouldn't be pay differences.
Like we'd all have this,
we'd all be on the same slate.
So maybe I'll switch it to a degree.
I actually don't want kids,
but if I were to decide to do that,
I would want them to grow up in that environment where there's no difference
between you two.
You don't have like a curfew that she doesn't have or vice versa.
I agree with you,
but I also think that we have like where we are now,
we wish there was a perfect world so we want to raise our kids and say treat
everyone the same.
Yes,
absolutely.
You treat everyone the same but recognize that not everyone believes that way.
I'm like if we teach our boys the responsibility that they have not taking
advantage of someone when they've had too much to drink.
I just think that there's an awareness that you have to teach boys being men and
also girls like becoming women
feminists.
Okay.
Three.
Two.
Okay.
I just think that feminism in recent years have just become extreme ones like
the 60s it's likely if you're a feminist then like your anti and tight hands
like you know,
I don't think it should be anti man.
I think we should all be empowering men to support women to write and bringing
them into the conversation.
I think right now feminism is like,
we don't need you.
Right?
Do I agree with that?
But also I think that women have been put down for so long that we kind of need
to go a little bit extreme in the opposite direction just so that we can come to
the middle because otherwise the men aren't going to meet us in the middle.
Well,
feminism by default is sort of the idea to make decisions for yourself and what
fuels you and telling a woman she should do something is actually antifeminist
because we're told all the time from so many people what we should be,
how we should act,
how we should address,
how we should communicate.
So the question,
and it goes against what I believe as a feminist.
Anyway,
one,
here we go.
Hi Guys.
Uh,
I think it's circumstantial because I do believe there are instances where if
the mother is,
I'm going to be severely harmed by a birth,
that that is where abortion would be.
Okay.
In my belief,
and I think it also the exception also would be in the cases of rape.
Um,
but all other circumstances where you made a choice.
I'm pro pro life,
I think we all deserve a chance at life.
So I definitely stuck in the,
I agree with that statement,
but I feel like the heavier restrictions that are placed on it by our government
just dictating what we can do with our bodies is really infuriating.
And then seeing people who have kids and resent it for the rest of their lives
and raising children that they never wanted.
It's frustrating.
And so do you think that those parents that are struggling with raising their
children that they didn't have the option for adoption or other ways?
It depends.
Like for a lot of cultures adoption is not okay.
So they would not be able to do that.
Wow.
Taste fully is the word that I,
that comes to mind.
Like I enjoy a tasteful,
you look fantastic.
Right?
That's true.
If it's wanted it's fine,
but then like you can't mind read,
how would you know?
We've all had like bad flirting experiences.
But then like I'm thinking there's a couple I've had where they're like,
excuse me,
I just wanted to let you know you're very beautiful,
please have a nice day.
And I'm like,
okay,
thank you.
You know,
and like something like that that's like short and sweet and there's no
expiration shit.
I think that's the thing.
I mean,
and I'm from,
and I'm from New York,
so I'm just like automatically on autopilot.
I don't talk to me to look at me like my whole life you had the cat calls,
but you have like the derogatory cat calls off or I don't look at you if I don't
speak to you,
I'm a be,
I'm,
I'm all of these things.
But it's like,
but if I did gave you the time of day,
then what would I be?
And I don't think like every guy is like that,
but it's just so much easier and safer.
Yeah.
Assume that nothing is in,
it's not a good way to live,
obviously.
But that's okay.
Well because then my question is is who gets let in and how do you determine who
gets let in and how do you function
if they start the,
I guess,
relationship in a non romantic or sexual way?
Like if it's not like a flirty,
it's just like you just meet people places and they just talk to you.
Yeah,
you can just talk to you like a normal person.
Three,
two.
Why?
Well at the heart of it,
I think that the me too movement is about women that have been in situations,
whether it's work or personal,
where they haven't been in a safe space to speak up or share and the burden
that's on us to protect men or other people by not speaking.
What has happened to us is actually can be like PTSD.
It's like traumatic to your system.
Like I experienced going through being sexually harassed and this happened in
2013 and I still have never come out about it.
Statistically speaking,
like the number of women who are raped,
there's exponentially more than who actually report it.
So when I think about the me too movement,
like there's strength in numbers,
you know,
when it started I was like,
I don't know if I want to post about this.
I don't know how I feel.
But what it did do was it gave me the strength to actually share with someone
else.
I like,
I'm realizing as everyone's talking,
like the reason I'm not in that line is because when me too was a big movement,
I didn't have the strength or courage to be a part of it.
So in my mind it's like still there of like if I,
I didn't have the courage to be a part of the movement and I still don't have
the courage to stand in that line because it's almost admitting that I've had
like multiple things happen,
you know?
And so you're representing all of the other women that feel the same way and
they see you and they relate to you on that.
So you're helping other women by saying that.
Yeah.
Three,
two,
one.
Ooh,
okay.
How is that any different than saying I believe that the world would be better
for it.
We run by men like if we're going to say that on this token we get that.
On that token,
that's not even balanced.
I think what my thought processes is in the current state that we're in right
now,
then think that it would be once we get to the place where we are able to raise
our children the same way and like women aren't afraid to like go outside and
like guys don't have like toxic masculinity.
Then it's like anybody can run the country and like it's all going to be the
same because we're all raised the same.
But I think for right now in the place that we're in,
I think women have a better understanding of that,
but I think it's hard because when you have little boys that are growing up that
are just not even accountable or nor should they be for things that men their
father's might've done or their grandfathers and then saying like woman should
be running the world.
It's the same thing where how is that different than in the 1957 year old little
girls were told men should be in positions of power.
Maybe if we had more women in leadership in c suite,
in,
in Congress.
Like what if we have more women in leadership period.
It doesn't have to be running the world maybe,
but if we just had more women and women of color,
different backgrounds,
like if we had more diversity in general in leadership around the world,
it would be a better place.
That's why I chose this one too cause I don't think it should be one or the
other.
I definitely think that uh,
what,
it's only a mountain run.
They're missing the rest of society.
You can't really operate the world or any government or leadership if you're not
embracing the second half of society.
I think the problem with what some people think feminism is,
is that you have to bring people down in order to raise people up.
But you don't have to do that.
Like you can raise women up to be in positions of power without pushing men
down.
And I think that that is a misconception with feminism.
Okay.
I need water.
Hey guys,
I'm Kendra.
Thank you so much for watching that episode.
Spectrum.
If you like what you saw,
make sure you subscribe,
falls on Instagram,
leave a comment below and we'll see you next time.